- [Narrator] Salmon sushi isn't Japanese.
It's Norwegian.
- [Woman] Huh?
Mm, sushi.
- [Narrator] Okay, here's the story.
Until about 1995, raw salmon
was not consumed in Japan
and this was for one big reason.
Pacific salmon has parasites,
so no salmon sushi,
sashimi, no spicy salmon, nothing.
- [Woman] What?
No way.
- But, obviously
that all changed thanks
in part to this guy.
- [Bjorn] Yes, my name
is Bjørn Eirik Olsen.
- [Narrator] Norway had a problem.
They had a lot of salmon
and too small a market.
Looking east, they set
their sights on Japan,
a country that loves raw fish so much,
it's willing to pay five times
the price for sushi-grade.
So, Norway formed a
committee and hired Bjørn.
- [Bjorn] From 1986 to 1991,
I worked for Project Japan.
- [Narrator] Their job was to
convince Japanese consumers
that Atlantic salmon
was safe to consume raw,
and this was hard.
Just take, for example, pork.
If some guy from Norway
came here and said,
here, eat our pork meat raw.
It's safe, it's really yummy.
We'd be like man, you're crazy.
- [Bjørn] It was basically
a matter of perception,
so we had to change the
whole country's opinion.
- [Narrator] Bjørn and
his team got to work.
They made the first-ever salmon rolls
and served them to businessmen in Japan,
which they didn't like for a long time.
- [Bjørn] It took actually 10 years
to get the proper
breakthrough in the market.
- [Narrator] So, there it is.
Salmon sushi didn't exist before 1995.
Bjørn, on behalf of the
world, we thank you.
(gentle instrumental music)